what is it about this character that
makes it appealing well I really I love
as I read the
only read the one scene she had from the
pilot before I signed on and in it she
is she abuses an elderly person under
her care and I just was sort of I've
always been sort of very interested by
deviant behavior and like the kind of
person that feels so small and Petty
that they have to you know they take
power in these ways and Misty is such a
fun character because she's always been
rejected you know she has no social
currency she's not cool she's not hot
she's not funny and she's missing sort
of this moral compass that everybody
else has but somehow it allows her to
even through like her isolation and
being rejected she just has the most fun
she loves chaos she never has the same
like pathos as anybody else you know she
doesn't really understand why everyone
feels so ashamed of everything all the
time and she just like has a really good
time and is wonderfully passive
aggressive and it's just fun